all
is god interacting with god
all is one infinite creator
expressing itself interacting with
itself whether it's awareness
interacting with other awareness
or whether it's awareness interacting
with
objects the appearances of form
whether it's the sensations or
perceptions or beliefs or emotions
or thoughts or feelings that arise
as the transient clouds in that sky that
is eternal and shared of awareness
all of this is god interacting with
itself
all of this is one infinite creator
expressing itself and interacting with
itself
how clear is the analogy
and how childlike is it of
the eye the i
is such a powerful and simple
analogy for us you have the pupil
the pupil is the eternal shared observer
witness awareness across
all 8 billion of us
the iris around the pupil is the unique
coloration it's the expression of
infinity that we are artistically
bringing
a gift into this dreamed creation design
even speaking from a place of science in
terms of dna and the code of life you
have the 99.9 percent
similarity which is
the pupil between humans
and then you have the point one percent
difference
which is the iris the unique coloration
look at it like the pair of eyes
on each of us that have a unique color
palette
in between that unique color palette in
between the eyes
is the unique iris around the pupil
and that is interacting with itself
infinity or source or god interacting
with itself
when it looks at another human
that has its own unique color palette
in the iris around the pupil
so it's god source infinity interacting
with itself across these dreamed
agents and also interacting with itself
across the appearance of all of this
form all these clouds of emotions
thoughts
perceptions feelings beliefs sensations
and the appearance of form of the
beautiful
trees and plants and animals
and oxygen and buildings and governments
and economies
resources
evolution the appearance of the music
the appearance of the modulations of
underlying energy quantum mechanically
that appear as
form that appear as matter
this is but one song and to recognize
infinity expressing itself as this one
song which we've eternally been doing
across all of these different
possibilities of songs
and to know yourself as that
always interacting with itself which is
why this leads to the eradication of
malevolence
you can't hurt another being
because you recognize it is the one
infinite creator
that's why love is the recognition that
we share that being
this is why it becomes like lao tzu said
in the doubt doubted ching it becomes
becomes this effortless action that we
channel morally outward
as we weave like the tantric path our
enlightened realizations into the social
fabric
because everything that we do is in the
butterfly
effect of maximizing planetary
prosperity
because we recognize the other is
actually
the self it's the one infinite creator i
am god you are god we are all that
we are all it
and that's where the maximizing of
prosperity comes in as well
all that we do upon this realization is
recognize that
our best way to express ourselves
is by architecting the frameworks and
protocols that maximize planetary
well-being
and abundance
recognizing yourself as god
that god realization when awareness
becomes
aware of awareness and how eternal
and shared that is that is metaphysical
truth
and when you recognize your eternal
source
and how you are a creative expression of
that in these
infinite modulating landscapes
you've anchored this metaphysical truth
the light bulb has went from flickering
to
staying on permanently you got it
but you have to know yourself as the one
infinite creator
you have to know yourself as an
expression of that you have to know this
dream
creation design as one of an infinite
amount of modulating landscapes
you have to know your maximum potential
as eradicating malevolence and suffering
and maximizing prosperity and abundance
and well-being
that's what's meant by know thyself know
thyself
what was written on the top of the
temple of apollo at delphi
2 500 years ago by the greeks
means to know yourself as god to know
yourself as god
interacting with god to know yourself as
god
interacting with these clouds of
experience to know yourself
as the eternal sky of god that is
experiencing the appearance of all of
these different modulations of form of
matter
and that's what's also taught by the
parable of the prodigal son when you go
outward seeking happiness and peace
externally in the appearance of form and
matter
just to recognize that you can't
actually extract
peace and happiness from the dream
creation design
that's when the turn inward happens
after you hit that breaking point
of being a contracted energy of an egoic
finite biological creature and as you go
inward to recognize
the eternal shared witness observer that
we
are you become aware of awareness itself
very subtle that's when the contracted
egoic finite biological entity dissolves
like a moth
that gets zapped by the white source
light
and it expands and it relaxes
and it becomes that infinitude that then
expresses itself creatively from the
absolute highest
morality perfectly in tune with the
symphonic expression
no longer playing out of tune and
creating ecological disaster
and chasing substances and peak
experiences and the transient material
possessions
and conspicuous consumption and greed
and narcissism and all of these
pathologies
but recognizing that the diamond
necklace around each of our necks
is already there waiting for us to
recognize it
and that is eternal peace and happiness
the awareness the observer the witness
that is uniquely refracting the source
light through each of our
jewels as the artistic expression
bringing a unique gift into the creation
design
and so our most upstream issue
is simply egoic leadership
you have 2 200 billionaires around the
planet you have 225 000
ultra high net worth individuals and
families that means people that own
30 million plus in assets us dollars
you have all of the fortune 500 ceos
we have the 200 united nations general
assembly we have the
535 people in usa congress all
of these people in leadership across the
planet
our most upstream issue is the very fact
that
they butterfly effect out to the vast
majority of people because they are in
those positions of leadership
and if they butterfly effect out egoic
states of consciousness because they
themselves are the contracted finite
biological egoic creature then
that's domino effecting outward
and catalyzing malevolence
it's catalyzing greed it's catalyzing
separation
and so awakening
and enlightening the leadership
of our planet is the most upstream
solution to all of our downstream issues
one
fortune 500 ceo that experiences satori
that pierces the veilless veil the
gateless gate and that recognizes
themselves as eternity infinity
expressing itself
that sees the others as a unique
expression of that infinitude that we
share our being when they recognize that
love
boom domino effect butterfly effect down
to
all thousands of their employees and
all thousands or even tens of thousands
or more people around the planet that
they reach with their product and
service
their mission their vision their ethos
becomes more enlightened
that's why it's the most upstream
god realization for the people that are
in the positions of leadership around
our planet is the most
upstream solution to all of the
downstream issues that we face
and this is also told in the parable of
the rich fool from luke 12 13
where you have the wealthy that gain
these massively
abundant harvests and rather than
storing the extra
in the stomachs of their brothers and
sisters and maximizing
the potential of all and becoming rich
with god
instead they store it they build more
and more storage facilities and store it
and then they have to get
security and they have to store and
protect it
and you see this is very analogous to
the modern swiss banks
to the union bank of switzerland that
has
over 50 percent of the planets
billionaires that bank with them 1
100 or so of them more
and more encryption more and more
security
more and more fear of the other more and
more i need to store
my excess my gold my stocks all of my
material possessions
all of my billion dollar art and
properties
and yachts and planes
and designer merchandise
do you see how the story was told over
2000 years ago
and yet we still are repeating the same
mistakes wake up especially
leadership around the planet
you are the most upstream solution to
our downstream problems
your enlightenment is the number one
thing
that we can do to maximize our potential
and we can leverage science and we can
leverage biometric
analysis to be able to tell at levels of
eeg
or fmri or hrv with heart rate
variability
we can tell your level of consciousness
if you're attached to the clouds if you
don't know yourself as the sky we can
tell that
scientifically via biometrics
your level of relaxation
has a strong influence on your body's
levels of cortisol the stress hormone
it has a strong influence on your heart
rate variability
so the number one thing we can do is to
take
the egoic leadership around the planet
and enlighten them
and focus on that so that the maximal
butterfly effect the maximal dominoes
will fall towards the direction of
maximizing planetary prosperity
and that's why simulation and this atlas
unit
are here in los angeles to catalyze
the awakening with the greatest
influences and celebrities
and to get them to recognize that this
is all god interacting with god that
this is all source
interacting with source infinity
interacting with
infinity
you are it interacting
with it here's a way to
also visualize it
this is one of my favorite memes
and super deeply appreciative of my
friend
conscious genius richard for sending
this over i love it so much god
is you standing on the edge of the cliff
god is also the life
situation that flicks you off of the
cliff
frequently called a trauma something
like a
parent dying or a spouse leaving you
or a job that you get
let go from god is also the cliff
that you got flicked off of god is also
the air
in the ocean god is also the hand
that catches you
from being flicked off of the cliff and
that's typically called the treasure
the trauma leads to the treasure but
only the wise recognize it
fast only the wise know how to
communicate
the story of how they experience the
greatest treasure from the greatest
traumas
and to share that with people having a
high digital quotient knowing how to
memetically put that
out into the world and awaken other
people to that
recognizing all of this is god
interacting with god
so therefore awareness is it
it is god it's the sky but
also all of the appearances of form
are god all of the clouds are god
all of the thoughts emotions experiences
feelings sensations perceptions all of
the appearances of form
as these objects of matter are god also
so you interacting with another agent of
infinity another
human that is god
you are it they are it you're
interacting
with that source or infinitude as
expressions of it
very similar to when you're engaging
with this microphone that's enabling you
to communicate
same thing with these lights and these
cameras and these computers
that this is all god and you are
interacting with
it it is interacting with you
there is no separation that's what the
non-dual wisdom
says it is all infinity it is all source
it is all god interacting with itself
we will never come to the end of
exploration we will never come to the
end of infinity
you can't ever finish putting together
all of the possibilities of musical
notes
in a song this is but one song
this is but one artistic expression on a
canvas
on a blank canvas
this is but one modulation of underlying
energy
that is emptiness appearing as this
creation design
we can never come to the end
that's why there's no beginning that's
why there's no end
and that's why there's no separation
in this one creation design
there is a beginning of some sort of a
big bang
and there's an end of some sort of a
godhead of the
head of the snake that then eats its own
tail
and that's the cyclic cosmology that's
the eternity
that's why sir roger penrose who won the
nobel prize in physics in 2020
has a cyclic cosmology even physics
the world's cutting edge in science is
agreeing with what spirituality has
known for thousands of years
that's when you know the ultimate
synthesis is here
that's when you know it's all pointing
to the one
end different faces of the mountain
different paths
pointing to the same one and the
ultimate synthesis
of science and spirituality
and this is why it's also known as the
most
important synthesis
the two forces that have driven us to
where we're at today
are spirituality and science
and to adore them both in that synthesis
is so critical
so again it's source interacting with
source it's inner
infinity interacting with infinity it's
god
interacting with god it's the absolute
interacting with the absolute it's the
ultimate
interacting with the ultimate brahman
interacting with brahman
dao interacting with dao
the universal wave function interacting
with the universal wave function the
multiverse interacting with the
multiverse
this is it
this is the absolute
this appearance of this atlas unit
running this enlightenment media company
that is then communicating
to these audiences of others
expressions of infinity that are then
listening
to this content this is the appearance
of the absolute
and to know yourself as that
as an appearance of the absolute as a
unique
expression of the absolute
and to be completely centerless
to recognize that even the agent
is itself dreamed even the witness the
observer
awareness itself is dreamed that is
absolute realization
all is the absolute infinity
god the ultimate interacting with
itself dao brahman
all is this
interacting with and that's why
rupert spira says that love is the
recognition that we share
our being you immediately eradicate
malevolence
upon this god realization upon
realization of yourself as an expression
of infinity
you recognize that everybody else is an
expression of infinity as well
and you immediately begin becoming
significantly more conscious and
channeling the absolute highest morality
towards others butterfly affecting like
the tantric
path your enlightened realizations into
society
into our geopolitical relations into
our relations with the planetary ecology
that literally sustains us
we each take 20 000 breaths a day thanks
to the photosynthesis that happens from
phytoplankton and trees
and so we no longer recognize ourselves
as separate from those phytoplankton and
trees but we recognize ourselves as
deeply one with them deeply
interdependent
for those twenty thousand
beautiful inhalations every single day
all is one infinite creator
interacting with itself
recognize that metaphysical truth
and all else will unfold so
flawlessly so harmonically
so frictionlessly
maximizing prosperity
for everybody
you deserve 24 7 peace and happiness
not 10 minutes a little glimpse of it
and everybody deserves to actualize
their fullest
artistic potential
and when we know ourselves as the one
infinite creator expressing itself when
we know ourselves as
god interacting with god source
interacting with source
infinity interacting with infinity
we eradicate all malevolence and we
maximize
planetary prosperity
thank you so much for tuning in i adore
you all
thank you if the video brought you value
give it a like
if you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel please leave a comment below
with your thoughts i'd love to hear from
you
and share the video with those that you
know
it would make a profound influence on
if you like join the channel get
exclusive perks
in the membership every single dollar
goes right into
actualizing the full potential of all of
our projects
and that is all one
infinite creator expressing itself
all is god interacting with god
source interacting with source infinity
interacting with infinity that
realization
eradicates malevolence and maximizes
prosperity you gotta go
inward first to go outward
right it's the sure cause of delight
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure cause of
[Music]
delight one
infinite creator expressing itself
hey one infinite creator expressing
itself hey one
infinite creator expressing itself hey
you